drawn sword from oh by dr. Jung ah ah
it's like I'm back to my naturist roots
haha text behind give me back my words
obstacle funds wait just a minute
I didn't even get a chance to do
anything you hold you you suck okay here
little kitty I'm gonna try to reason
with you I've got a bunch of swords
you're an [ __ ]
so what am I supposed to do about this
oh what's that what what you want some
candy soda for candy I killed your
mother how do you feel about that now oh
wait Oh what what what's the matter you
look a little sad you look good
water in your eyes what they let me mop
it up with this Santa's not real well
alright then
hey we know this isn't really a
challenge when you can go right over
them uh okay yeah i know i'm a giant
wimp here we go come on there we go oh
wait woo oh right through my head how
about you go [ __ ] yourself huh hello
that our love will keep us safe it's
okay my darling
No and what's over here that's look
normal
oh I know I said I was gonna do a last
try but I've changed my mind
we well [ __ ] it out
Trigon oh oh come on give me the diamond
no my diamonds warning this doesn't
always were the wheel of your Segway a
[ __ ] structions
Oh too much reading give me I hear grab
one I'm gonna call will grab your ass
give me that
ha no ha dog cat come out of it
grain rainbow ball throw rainbow come on
matrix what what hey I'm not I'm not
doing it out what what did I do
okay now the objective of this is to not
kill yourself I know you have a very
depressing life you had to draw your
friends but seriously let's not kill
ourselves here oh what the [ __ ]
okay neon head throw hey wait whoa I go
backwards when I want to go flowers ergo
how did I do that you can fly I can fly
today Mike ah
ow all right Curtis her sir do you get
me through less you'll get to get the
entertainment warmer ninety-nine point
now I'm sure I'm gonna do just fine here
we go yeah some balls
huh you're my mother
good thing I've got so many repressed
memories
let's see kill - kill kill them all
kill them all can tell that off
all this has been happy wheels
highlights thanks for watching if you
like what you saw and you want to see
more why not subscribe to my channel
want to help the channel grow
leave a like add it to your favorites or
share it with your friends on Facebook
and Twitter thanks again and as always I
will see you in the next video